okay today's topic a lot of people have
been interviewing andrew taylor who's
andrew tate uh he's a brickhill guy uh
yes i think he's a former kickboxer and
i think now he's more of like
when the guru multi-millionaire lives
out in romania it's a hypothetical let
me change it you and your woman are
asleep in bed upstairs you hear someone
break into the house downstairs who goes
downstairs nobody
execute you're tripping hold up hold x2
so you're not going down there
nobody's going down there so what if
they come upstairs bro you gotta put you
gotta protect you i'll keep it a buck
protect real quick real quick i'll keep
it a buck fifty no no my job is to
survive not protect
my job is to survive and sometimes that
means to get the good on
that sounds crazy doesn't it that sounds
crazy right because you're not
acknowledging
though okay you know what you know what
you know what go for it
maybe you are not gonna go outside
you're gonna not you're not gonna go
downstairs maybe you are not okay
i'll take it
i'll take it
i'll take it
but for real i'll take it you're maybe
you're not going to go out downstairs
but he's asking a general question and
i've had the feeling that you sensed
where you was going so you went on the
defensive motion ah nobody's going
outside uh my job is
okay
let's stick to a general question
in general
who is going
downstairs nobody should that's not what
the question was
in general
who is going
downstairs what if your girl's a mma
fighter
who
is going
downstairs what if what
yeah so what if she's robocop
bro my girl is a whole [ __ ] black
belt in taekwondo go tell them i'm going
downstairs
we all know she's a whole black belt
right so technically better than me can
lift her foot that high
i'm going downstairs okay so we all know
that stop right so when a red pill guy
says
you have an imperative to defend your
woman it's like yes we all know this
intrinsic yes okay and so i had a
conversation x briefly and it was cool
and i asked him the question a bit
differently i want you guys here
hypothetical there's a gun pointed at
the both of you all right do you feel
like it's your responsibility to get in
front of your girl before the gun goes
off
uh no no
no
okay
okay okay what if it's your child
um
i mean see these hypotheticals we're not
gonna like going anywhere with that i i
just said these type of things are very
very bad
but
understand the principle i'm not talking
about the technical aspect you
understand the principle of it it's like
it's like
but by principle yes
by technicality i feel like um
there if there could be choices to make
that are better you can make a better
choice
right what type of gun it is
oh my god
what type of gun is it oh my god hold on
hold on hold on
let give him a chance to explain
i know it sounds crazy
uh yeah i'll shut up i'll shout out
we'll give him a shot
like i think this is a question about
like just the principle of it right
this is just the principle if you if i
don't get anything
okay okay okay god god bless you that
was the only word i had i thought we got
so far off the the the deep end that we
wouldn't say yes that cause i mean and
if you can as well like i mean uh
i i i i just want you to understand like
how it comes across to everyone in the
world when when they hear you even
hesitate because if you ask most men
on the street vast majority of people
and you said listen there's a gun point
at you and your girl would you they
would all jump and immediately say yes
especially if it was their kids they
wouldn't even think about it so when
they even hear you hesitate all of a
sudden they look at you like you're
crazy yeah even even if they themselves
wouldn't do it they'd still answer yes
to it of course right oh yeah yeah
because they want to [ __ ] answer but
no no
but the thing that happened is that that
answer that answer is the answer of
someone that's never been in a situation
that was like
dangerous
and that's fine because a lot most of
the people in the world hasn't been in
that situation right which is which is
fine which is fine which is fine when
[ __ ] like that happen you do not have to
it's not even you it's not even your
brain talking it's not your brain being
like okay that's the type of gun this
person is like that if i take his way
that's not even that that's movies
that's the equalizer starring dan denzel
washington that's counting down but
that's not real life
even if you even you're in a
fight-or-flight situation situation and
you
there's a guy attacking you
you could take the classes
martial art classes that you that you
think and that you have and whatever
whatnot the first error that someone
that takes martial arts class is
thinking that they know how to fight
when that situation happens
it's [ __ ] you're not you don't rely on
your knowledge you rely on what you
repeated and you're you have to train
your body to act that way without you
even thinking okay that's the thing
right there
no my dude you
don't think
you don't have the time to think you
don't have the time to assess stuff
that's not the real world which is fine
it's fine it's fine but like you said in
that clip
it really makes
you're crazy dude
okay listen on the woman thing i could
semi understand if someone brings up
your child
i don't think look maybe i'm crazy like
i've got nieces and nephews i love
anybody it wouldn't even be a hesitation
at least
my instinct
some people are gonna say yeah i would
defend my girl and maybe they wouldn't
do it in the moment but most people have
that instinct or want to have that
instinct and so when you say like i
don't know maybe maybe i won't it sounds
crazy to people right and this emboldens
a lot of folks to follow all these red
pill dudes because their paradigm sounds
far more appealing and much more natural
than what you're explaining go to any
man and say well maybe you don't go to
defend your child think about it they
were like what the [ __ ] it's my kid of
course i'm gonna die for my kid are you
crazy
so when they hear you say anything
otherwise they throw everything that you
have to say out the window i'm gonna
talk to these red pill dudes because
they sound way more reasonable
and a lot of folks go through this
pattern where they're having these
conversations with these people and then
start to embolden them and make them
sound more appealing because at the end
of the day they do sound more sensible
they do even a woman even a woman
with her child of course and there's a
dude she will jump in front to save the
child yeah if the dude don't react
enough if it's just her and the dude
she's probably going to look at the dude
but if it's her child that's crazy dude
let me let me ask all the women who are
watching right now leave a comment below
ladies if you found that your man would
hesitate to save your how fast is your
[ __ ] gonna dry up
so how quickly are you turning into the
sahara desert
desert is gonna fool [ __ ] moving that
pump let's go
uh yeah listen they all dry nobody cares
sand lane like your [ __ ] boom boom okay
let's be honest we know what it is a
whole biscuit in the panties
when you have feminists and red pill
guys agreeing on this concept because i
promise you every feminist below would
be like i would expect my
partner to save our child everything
when you got them both agreeing you have
to understand how your stain sounds
ridiculous so you cannot be so against a
lot of this stuff
that you start to sound that way but
then not to to be fair to him he didn't
roll the backs like yeah okay if i would
want to defend mine but it's the
hesitation and even the the weirdness
with it that sounds bad but you just
saying that you just saying that i can't
have a conversation with you what you
mean cause the conversation's gonna be
dishonest why you're not even gonna i'm
gonna ask you
that's dishonesty you're dishonest you
know damn well you're gonna try to
protect or you really are crazy but if i
if i look at you and you lit if you if
you talk like that i'm gonna be like
i can't talk with you
yeah that's that's your answer that that
question or maybe you guys are just
operating on such different paradigms
like it's like yeah it's like you you
you we're not even it's like you're
justifying yourself based off science
the other person's like well god told me
it's like i'm like i can't wait i can't
talk to you you're not missing not just
because you're nonsensical because we're
not even talking about we're not we
don't even have the same basis it's
something that i've noticed a lot when i
would see the interviews that some
people would do either be it with fresh
and fit or this guy or some people it's
like you have to give ground on some
stuff because the ground that they're
standing on makes sense
you know when they talk about the fact
that women do generally desire men who
make their income or above you can't
just say everything that's a fact no not
me that's something that we've been
saying before we ever knew any of these
guys that's a fact that's a fact right
yes women like men who are bigger
stronger taller than them that's a fact
there's exceptions to the rule but they
generally like that so when guys are
telling you go live go take care of your
fitness it makes sense you can't just
throw everything don't throw out don't
throw the baby out with the bath water
yeah
it applies here there's some shed right
and if you can find that middle ground
you can find the stuff that's in that uh
ideology that makes sense and that can
be helpful to you because let me be
honest with you when i was learning and
it wasn't called red pill back then but
when it was just like pick up artist
stuff when you're learning how to
approach women or how to talk to and all
this stuff there was a lot of stuff in
there in terms of building
self-confidence in terms of getting
better in a lot of aspects right that is
extremely useful so me i'm watching all
these conversations unfold of course
this guy's gonna win on most of these
debates or seem more interesting to the
public it's like the alternatives don't
sound really appealing right
you're talking about dudes who are
either out of shape don't live desirable
lives don't have all the stuff that they
would that the general populace would
want in an ideal life it's like here's
an example it's like
a five foot one out of shape dude trying
to give you fitness advice even though
he may have all the science even though
me all the facts they're going to go
listen to a big dude who's in better
shape because he seems to be living
whatever it is that he's
because the thing might work whenever
they drop in your dm in fact do you want
to increase your followers and you look
at their followers and they got two i'm
like [ __ ] go increase yours yeah go
increase your followers and then talk to
me about my [ __ ] followers right i'm
sitting here with 20 000. you got five
and that's a scam and so there's no
alternative to these dudes they go in
they will win these a lot of these
discussions it looks like a scam
if if you don't live the life you look
like you're living the life i'm gonna be
like why why are you out there teaching
me yeah you're not using
it
it makes sense yep
so just just understand that and guys
get ready this whole red pill stuff is
going to invade your tik tok it has
already to some degree it's going to be
all over youtube it's going to be
talking points on the news i see that's
where it's going in the future already i
started absolutely i think there's going
to be a lot of pushback against it but
undoubtedly all the mainstream people
are picking up on it because it gets
views it gets clicks so just get ready
for that and then yeah
if you're gonna argue against something
or hate it know what you hate
because a lot of you have no idea what
the [ __ ] this [ __ ] is you have no idea
what it represents or what it does for
men or how it helps them or why it's
even needed you don't know you don't
care to know you just heard some [ __ ]
you didn't like and it sounded funny
based off your ideology so you're like
[ __ ] them that's not gonna cut it
it's not gonna cut it because i see
dudes are really gravitating toward this
stuff and it's inevitable and i'm not
even mad at them people think that
people like yo abba do you why don't you
try to pull more of these red pill
because i'm not giving them an
alternative do you think i'm going to
run a coaching program
do you think i'm going to spend time
talking to all these young men who are
lost and need some mentorship and i'm
going to spend time trying to guide them
i don't have the time
i don't have the energy so i'm not going
to tell them not to go follow any of
these dudes if you want to and if it
helps you hey man go do you go do i'ma
just say hey man there might be some
stuff that's off about it but otherwise
go do whatever you want to do because
there's nothing else out there
what do you how are you going to get
resources on how to approach ladies who
going to teach you
anything else you want to say no
protecting your kids are basic
that's amazing sound crazy that's the
best you sound [ __ ] crazy